happy Star Wars Friday everybody so we
got to freak out about episode 8 force
Friday stuff happening this year so I'm
gonna explain what's going on and what
it says about the movie if you guys
didn't know I'm doing Star Wars Fridays
where I do a Star Wars bonus video every
Friday no matter what's going on during
the week so if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get
everything and leave all your requests
in the comments below but the big thing
this Friday everyone's freaking out
about is they revealed force Friday to
packaging that actually gives us a look
at Rey's character and it confirms a
couple big things about the movie there
are some other things that drop that
also back that up that I'll explain but
really this is all about Rey's character
so I'll say new round of the Star Wars
giveaway starts now it's for a copy of
the rogue 1 DVD all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
Star Wars comment on this video the 10
big takeaways from this are number 10 if
you don't remember what Star Wars force
Friday is it was a giant worldwide toy
unboxing event where they revealed all
the new toy lines based on the new
movies we'd already gotten a looks at
some of the packaging so you had a
pretty good idea what some of the black
series look like but it was basically
this
every one
[Music]
you looking for somebody well yeah check
it out - gosh number nine the really
cool thing is I'll be doing some stuff
for that later this year - of course
I'll be giving away a lot of Star Wars
toys when the movie gets ready to come
out it'll be a lot of fun but Star Wars
force Friday - is happening this
September so you don't have to wait that
long the movie is not coming out till
December you do not have to wait till
December to get all those new toys
surprisingly that just seems like a good
business decision from Star Wars please
if you want to tell us to shut up and
take our money we will allow you to do
that number 8 the other thing that's
going to be coming back around is Rian
Johnson the director also T's cool stuff
for Star Wars Celebration that's
happening April 13th through the 16th I
know we do Star Wars Friday so I do Star
Wars videos every week anyway but that's
going to be a Comic Con style weekend
where there is just a bunch of Star Wars
stuff happening all within a really
small span of time it is going to be
crazy there's some larger stuff
rumblings behind the scenes that I'll
explain later on this list so number 7
the big stuff Rey has a very qui-gon
jinn looking haircut in this if you
remember Anakin's Padawan haircut he had
to shave side the braid male Padawans
have different hairstyles that female
padawan female Padawans look like this
it confirms a whole bunch of stuff in
connection with number 6 the updated
foreign titles there were new land
American and Italian posters posted to
the official Facebook pages of Star Wars
that confirmed plural Jedi so the last
of the Jedi just means that there is no
one single Jedi left so that's one
theory that you can cross off your list
it doesn't confirm who the last Jedi are
it just confirms that there's more than
one so it confirms Luke Rey but there's
also the theory that kylo Ren and even
Snoke could be the last Jedi because we
know so little about his backstory we
know a lot about him politically I did a
video about that because he has history
with Leia so I had a link at the end of
this but the reason why that's so huge
is just because even though there's a
seismic shift in the teachings of the
Jedi in these new films the Jedi term
will still apply it
much confirms that like they'll always
be Jedi in Star Wars even though they
won't look anything like the Jedi that
you've seen before number 5 the other
people on that poster Finn and Poe don't
really look any different than they did
in force awakens but characters go
through a number of different costume
changes during the movie Finn went from
its stormtrooper armor to being stripped
down to going to pose resistance jacket
there's a lot of rumors about what Finn
is doing in the movie so I'll briefly
address that but it's a little bit of
speculation it just implies that he's
going to be thrown back into the path of
the first order which gives us an idea
how we might run into the phasma
character because she is so important
for Finn's character if she's going to
show up again during episode 8 and they
D confirmed that she has a much bigger
part than she did in episode 7 the most
rewarding way to do that would be to
circle back around to the way she left
things with Finn throw him back into her
path so that she can get a little bit of
revenge but Finn can also carry out
whatever mission he's on because his
spine is healed he's standing up right
here and he wants nothing more than to
help the resistance now he is fully
committed to the cause there is some
speculation that goes a little bit
beyond that maybe I'll do that in a
separate video if you want to talk about
that there have been a lot of rumors
about what actually Finn is doing during
the movie you can do that in the
comments below but just remember that
it's speculation at this point number 4
the last Jedi so there were a lot of
theories like I said before this title
dropped about who that was we can't
discount kylo Ren
because Snoke looks like he's trying to
create a super Jedi they're talking
about a new order so it goes way beyond
what's happening with the Knights of Ren
the Knights of Ren is not the new order
that Snoke is making they're just an
elite group of dark side force users put
together by Snoke to carry out special
missions separate from the rest of the
first-order they're not the great force
wielders that he's hoping to create in
kylo Ren he actually had an apprentice
before he met kylo Ren so while most of
our focus is on Rey becoming a Jedi she
has the Padawan haircut she has the
lightsaber she's training with fluke you
cannot forget about kylo Ren being the
last of the Jedi number three on the
flip side of this how are the Jedi
changing so I did a video about the Ben
do the dive Ben do sort of the
beliefs of the Jedi in how they're being
incorporated into these new film so
while the term Jedi will still imply the
way they become Jedi's the way they
practice the force the way they wield it
will be very different so if you don't
watch Star Wars rebels and you didn't
see the Ben do video that I did it's
really just a different approach to the
force that does not discount the use of
the darkside it's sort of something in
the middle grade Jedi like ahsoka is
kind of a term for that but technically
she's not been do it just to clarify
when I say Ben do a lot of people were
confused about this the Ben do is not
the name of his race it's a very Yoda
type twist and that we don't know the
true name of Yoda species George Lucas
was famous for never truly revealing a
lot of Yoda's origins they were just
meant to be very mysterious so in that
way the Ben do is very mysterious then
do is the name of his order so it's like
calling someone a Jedi you go to see the
Jedi you go to see the Ben do but when
people think about Jedi training in the
old films you see Master Yoda lecturing
in the Jedi Temple people learning in
classes it's a very rigid way to learn
and wield the force these are the things
you're allowed to do you must be
passionless no attachments no spouses no
children the wrinkle in that during the
prequels was qui-gon jinn and his use of
the Living force so number two remember
that the prequels are still canon they
haven't changed the way that the living
force and the cosmic force work
midi-chlorians are technically still
canon even though they've erased all
mention of them from the new Star Wars
film do not expect to hear about
midi-chlorians even though technically
they still exist but the living force if
you didn't know is the energy field
generated by all living things it's what
enables qui-gon Yoda obi-wan Anakin to
become force ghost and continue speaking
with the living the cosmic force is the
connective tissue that connects
everything at a cosmic level across the
galaxy it's not really important but the
midi-chlorians are basically like the
Wi-Fi receptors in all living things
that allow the living force to connect
with the cosmic force so all this stuff
is still Canada but they're going to do
it in a really simple easy-to-follow way
in the new film the Jedi never spent a
lot of time in the old film studying the
Living force and they avoided
this is favored by dark side force users
that's part of what's changing in the
new film forget about the things they
told you not to do the things they told
you not to study we're going to be
learning a new way a new path so it just
confirms that there will always be Jedi
in Star Wars even though what the Jedi
look like the way they practice and
wield the force will be very different
imagine them trying to get rid of the
word Jedi it would be a crazy branding
nightmare it would be like trying to get
rid of the word lightsaber all the
merchandising would fall down the toilet
that's what made George Lucas a
billionaire not the film's the
merchandise made him all that money in
number one the really important thing
that's coming up pretty soon they've
confirmed a Star Wars Episode eight
panel at Star Wars Celebration April 13
through the 16th the panel is going to
be happening on Friday they're probably
going to bring a trailer like they did
to the episode 7 panel it's celebration
and a behind the scenes real they
brought way more than the episode 7
trailer when they came to celebration
there was a whole bunch of extra footage
too so it will be a really big deal
which is part of the reason why you
haven't seen an episode 8 trailer yet
because they're just waiting for that of
course I'm going to be doing a whole
bunch of videos for that but if you want
to suggest bonus Star Wars videos for me
to do each week before then just write
them below in the comments it seems like
most of you have like Star Wars Fridays
so far so I'm making that a permanent
thing Star Wars videos every Friday no
matter what's happening till the end of
time I'm going to be doing the same
thing for other stuff like Spider Man
the flash Sunday is usually supposed to
be a game of Thrones day for me but you
get the idea so we'll make a video
update when I decide what days are going
to be what videos but congratulations to
last week's Star Wars giveaway winner
Regan Hughes please private message me
on the back end of my channel so I can
get your contact details what's going to
happen next is is there is a mystery
name or Marvel project that is filming
in Hawaii so I'm going to do a video all
about that because it raises so many
questions so thank you so much for
watching I'll see you guys in that next
video while you wait for that you can
click here to learn all about snoke's
backstory and you can click here for the
Black Panther infinity War teaser video
vinicky me anything
[Music]